servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem wir heute eine
neue zellen spielen werden und zwar
heute hier in what the [ __ ] okay es
klingelt dankeschön mit in der aufnahme
gucken wer das ist beste moment einfach
dass das ist professionell vista leute
dass eine jacke an
wenn wir einmal ruhe aufnehmen es
klingelt natürlich spiel war richtig
anzieht kann ich auch mal wirklich mal
treppen laufen
lärm
wer lieber mit reinen millionen noch
unterschritt
sechseinhalb stunden später wo wir sind
ist wieder oben sting ist nie warm
wahrscheinlich ist es was zu essen so
leute es gab einfach gerade eben dass
hier mit der mit hydro mit der post
würde ich sagen wir schauen jetzt mal
rein
hier gibt es auf pizza burger denk an
dich oder mach das zwar leute hat glaube
ich angefragt dem testen möchte in dem
video diesen kids aber gott hat mir
europäischer bürger ist es was zu essen
machen wir natürlich und wir machen
heute eine pizza burger challenge und
zwar werden wir den games warum sie wenn
sie sich zum beispiel games werden wir
die challenge machen dass wir nach jedem
kill aber in diesen pizza burger herein
weißen müssen so also quasi mit mit
einer handspiel mit der ana hat den
pizza gegessen
ich hoffe das geht scheint zu gehen
und ja ich würd sagen ich bin jetzt mal
zu sg rüber und chor wie das ganze
funktioniert
so leute wir sind jetzt in der runde sg
der pizza burger ist hier weil wir jetzt
für jeden kirche wir machen einmal daran
weißen ich hoffe ich mache überhaupt
kills ehrlich gesagt weil nobody knows
alter ich bin lange lange nicht mehr auf
www bwin zeit auch regie war ich sowieso
noch nie also bisher weil das will ich
auf dem da kriege ich nur diverse
geschlechtskrankheiten und darauf hatten
wir glaube ich niemand wirklich bock das
hier ist okay damals schon ein schönes
essen erst das nehme ich gerne mit dem
gamepad mit ok erster erster klasse und
jetzt müssen wir weg laufen und dabei
diesen burger essen okay so also das
teilt tropft auf jeden fall schon mal
nicht dass es eine gute sache und es
passt perfekt leute weil ich sowieso
noch nichts gegessen hat sorgen zum
abend bot er macht aber viel zu viele
junge leute wie der schaden macht der
optimal bisher als alter folgen hat
diese type die jazz man wie fucking op
ist er aber kehrt bisschen geschafft
wird durch dieses treffen es ist eine
gute sache
jetzt müssen wir erstmal einen kleinen
spazieren hier machen sowas macht er lud
hier ganz entspannt die kisten alles
klar
wenn ich hier so ums überleben kämpfen
nur durch die kisten du gehst gebot
kreatur nice nicht erst getan hätten ich
bin nicht genügt ja kein wunder dass sie
mich zu tode tagen die leute denkt
natürlich nie daran dass mit einer
aufnahme ist und einfach versucht hier
die peoples zu unterhalten
ok meisten eisen leggins wird besser
wertungspunkte halten jetzt kommen alle
kann ich mich noch nicken
ich kann mich nicht alles gleich
mehrfach ich bin jetzt vier
dann schreibt niemand mehr irgendwelche
display perfekt ich habe nicht einmal
irgendeinen müll in den tschad rein wenn
z4 am start ist voll geil die kisten
wurden überhaupt nicht genug das gefühl
okay die hier schon kompass
zeigt mir in diese richtung wir sind
zwei gegner nebeneinander scheinbar
woher die kämpfen die kämpfen junge wenn
ich da abstauben kann ist gut live so
viele teams verboten
vielleicht teams natürlich auch okay er
hat ihn gekillt ist wahrscheinlich
selbst live jetzt gerade
und da kommt der essingen jay ein junior
bamm bamm bamm und er kriegt einen hit
der krieg noch ein hit ist noch eine
dann ist er dauernd safe dann mache
nicht mehr viel mit der du ja noch ein
ok hatte noch weggesteckt der kommt ja
auf einheit noch dann bist du weg bist
weg pro als auch noch eine frist das
wirklich kein thema blog ich natürlich
ja und er ist ein wunderbar heißt todes
equipment für uns erst mal hier und ein
weiterer bis in den burger kurz mal
sortieren hier equipment es auf jeden
fall am point leute kann sich nicht
beklagen wenn es leider kein fenster
liegt an finsternis was ich dass inter
liegen die hübschen ist eine full album
nachrüstungs punkten die 71 punkte sind
da so warm war okay da kommt einer und
ist dieser op die ag nicht vorschnell
getroffen hatte woanders wird er wie
gegen den das wird er wie gegen den es
sind vier leute im deathmatch leute
vielleicht packen das noch mal hier
nochmal in kiel zu holen oder eventuell
und es ist gar nicht so gut aus
alle locker dauern heißt es dauern wird
in eisen schwertes nämlich gerne mal mit
hier sehr schnell und der anderen seien
auch sydney wo ist denn diese idee kit
wo ist diese idee kit billigeren es aber
das ist nutzlos aber hier auf schnee
spielen klappt es trotzdem mal zusammen
mit dem ihr go go find ich ja noch ein
bisschen
auch in gekühltem und auch rein weißen
den bürgern final patmos er hat wie
ameisen schwer hat 467 halb acht und
halb rüstungs punkte hätten ganz
russland mehr als wir läuft gar nicht so
schlecht aber fängt ziemlich viele
powerups gefühl
da war die linke schon da
und es dann mit zement alter die
biospain prophezeiung ist wahr geworden
als wenn es noch mal hier
so das wars von heutigen challenge
wollen euch die gefallen hat könnte ein
link lasten link drei jungen alter okay
leute es wird nichts mehr heute danke
fürs duschen auf jeden fall bis zum
nächsten video morgen haut rein macht's
gut und ja